President Trump is in Paris right now he
will participate in a ceremony to
commemorate the centennial of the end of
World War one meanwhile there is a
battle if not a war continuing over his
immigration policy and specifically
tonight the matter of migrants claiming
they're coming to this country to avoid
persecution chief White House
correspondent John Roberts is in the
city of lights
tonight good evening John record mornin
to you from Paris well it certainly is a
legal battle with a lawsuit being filed
against the president just this
afternoon but President Trump says he is
determined to do whatever he can to stem
the tide of illegal immigration into the
United States departing the White House
this morning President Trump threw more
fuel on the immigration fire saying he
had started the process to deny asylum
claims made by illegal immigrants I just
signed the proclamation on Asylum very
important people can come in but they
have to come in through the ports of
entry that's to be is a very important
thing the action drew an instant lawsuit
from the ACLU with the president got
immediate backup from his acting
Attorney General Matt Whitaker in a
statement saying today the president has
made a strong statement that enough is
enough
thanks to this decisive order from
President Trump we are continuing to
provide a path to protection for those
who truly need it while stopping our
generosity from being abused I reiterate
we need Democrats votes they have to
pass
new immigration laws because they're
flooding our country we're not letting
them in but they're trying to flood our
country President Trump will be in Paris
to mark the hundredth anniversary of the
armistice that ended World War one while
the president will have a bilateral
meeting with French president Emmanuel
macron a sit-down with Russian President
Vladimir Putin has been put off until
later this month well I'll meet with
Putin at the g20 I don't know that we're
seeing each other in Paris but we may
that may be a lunch for the leaders Fox
News is told that after President Trump
returns from Paris he and his attorneys
will make a decision whether to submit
to an interview with special counsel
Robert Muller
right now I'm thinking about the world
I'm not thinking about sit downs and not
sit down the president's legal team has
prepared written answers to several
questions about the Russia collusion
issue but president Trump hasn't yet
decided whether he'll give them to
Muller
there was no collusion it's a whole hope
on his way to Paris aboard Air Force One
the president weighed in on
congressional efforts to protect the
Muller investigation with legislation
taking aim at Arizona Republican Jeff
Flake tweeting Jeff Flake he doesn't
want to protect the non senate-confirmed
special counsel he wants to protect his
future after being unelectable in
Arizona for the crime of doing a
terrible job and president Trump also
railed against the decision by an Obama
appointed district judge in Montana to
block his plans to build the Keystone XL
pipeline so is a political decision made
by a judge I think it's a disgrace
the president Trump did see as good news
a Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals ruling
against his plans to end the so-called
daca program good news because it now
kicks the case to the Supreme Court
where President Trump just cemented a
5-4 conservative majority right John the
president also reacting tonight to the
French president's support for a
European army what can you tell us about
that in a recent radio talk show of
French President Emmanuel macron said
that Europe needed to do more to protect
itself which might include a true
European army to protect against threats
such as Russia China even the United
States just before he landed president
Trump tweeted quote president McCrone
have France has just suggested that
Europe build its own military in order
to protect itself from the US China and
Russia very insulting but perhaps Europe
should first pay its fair share of NATO
which the u.s. subsidizes greatly
nothing like starting your weekend off
on a good foot John Roberts love in
Paris just past midnight John thanks